je crois qu'on a évolué je pense que le
miz la santé actuelle a compris et qu'il
a mais il a un objectif est à mon sens
ce qui aurait pu être plus rapide mais
je crois qu'il a compris qu'il fallait
faire énormément de tester que ça veut
dire ça arrive maintenant ou c'est
probablement un peu maintenant il ya
trop de cas actuellement mais le débit
est pas le même que ce qu'il était au
moment où on avait la vague et où il
était nécessaire ne serait-ce encore une
fois pour comprendre la maladie il faut
en faire le diagnostic
donc on ne peut pas envoyer désigner les
gens qui vont je vous donne un exemple
qui m'a beaucoup frappée il ya monsieur
chinois qu'avec 80 ans qui venait de la
zone dubai pas de l'uad d'accord qui
s'est présentée à la pitié salpêtrière
il y avait de la fièvre à 80 ans il
revenait de chine il n'a pas été testé
parce que santé publique a aidé il faut
tester que les gens de yuan s'ils ont de
la fièvre et de la toux
il est entré chez lui et on fait du sept
jours après après avoir contaminé sa
fille elle est venue mourir dans un
hôpital dans lequel on lui a donné du
rnd si bien d'accord donc c'est ça c'est
toute l'histoire qui s'est passé quand
même de a à z et donc ça pose une
question c'est d'abord il ya une
arrogance qui est de savoir comment vont
se présenter les malades sur une maladie
qu'on connaît pas ça c'est pas bien
d'accord et ça ça a été justifiée par le
fait qu'on peut pas faire de test mais
on peut pas faire de test parce que moi
au début on m'interdit de faire un test
encore une fois donc c'est jeu j'ai dit
écoutez je vous enverrai les positifs
pour que quelqu'un qui soit meilleur que
moi faire la pcr qui fasse les petits
mois je reçois de 10000 principalement
du monde pour faire les pcr monde entier
de la mayo clinic massachusetts general
hospital de londres monde entier mais je
ne pouvais pas faire en france d'un
moustique du coville donc il ya quand
même une réflexion et l'arrêtent mais la
réflexion encore une fois il ya des
choses qui sont un des responsabilités
humaines directes et il ya des choses
qui sont structurels je pense que si on
maintient un système de ses systèmes de
petits centres nationaux de référence
vous développerez des personnalités de
niche de blaireau dans leur terrier qui
montrent si on s'en approche
je pense que c'est comme ça c'est les
humains ils sont territoriaux et s'il
considère qu'une maladie et leur
territoire vous êtes perdus voilà je
vous le dis c'est comme ça parce que
c'est l'expérience de l'âge m'excuser
bien que ça serve à quelque chose de
vieillir et donc ça en tout cas je sais
ça si vous constituer des territoires
dans la république pour des problèmes
généraux
vous aurez des difficultés considérables
je me rappelle qu'il faut poser une fois
l'une après l'autre et donc n'a rien à
voir avec le manque découvrir non
c'était la question c'était sur le
nombre de vies sauvées par rapport à
votre protocole que vous avez fait
notamment et je ne peux pas dire y ait
un travail je ne sais pas dire il ya un
travail pour lequel nous on a fait une
opération grossière un qui vient de
d'être disponible à paris sur le
simplement le plaquer nil se voulait sur
4500 personnes on a comparé je sais pas
quoi 600 personnes qui ont reçu du
placali les puits les autres n'ont pas
reçu il ya une différence de mortalité
de 20 % maintenant on a calculé que ça
faisait 150 personnes c'est ce que je
sais les calculs de leur donner un tout
le monde c'est disponible
regardez et parmi les auteurs il ya
d'ailleurs beaucoup critiqué enfin la
vie et malicieuse c'est comme ça donc
c'est bien on verra bien sûr on se
trompe mais il faut être pondérés dans
ses dents avant d'avoir la connaissance
de ce qui se passe pour le bon il faut
être pondérés dans les commentaires
avant pour pas se faire attraper par
l'histoire donc en pratique je ne sais
pas il ya des choses qui ne sont pas il
ya deux éléments qui me paraissent être
des éléments inquiétants dans cette
question la proportion envoyer des gens
qui sont morts qu'en moins de 65 ans à
paris sur les données que j'ai de 17%
je vous rappelle que en europe elle est
de 10 % qui s'est passé quelque chose
ici sur la prise en charge la mortalité
dans les réanimations ici dans ce
travail toujours et le 43% chez nous
elle est de 16%
c'est les mêmes malades ils sont tous en
rire donc il ya quelque chose s'ils
voulaient il y a une âme on sens c'est
une les vrais il ya de vrais problèmes
pour moi en dehors des phénomènes
structuraux pour lequel c'est pas des
questions d'individus c'est les
questions structure c'est de décider de
ne pas s'acharner sur le soin et donc le
soin est passée au second plan
et on a même vu effectivement des
interdictions du visage de médicaments
qui sont génériques et qui ont été
distribués à des milliards de comprimés
parce que je vous rappelle que
l'hydroxyde le rock in ça a été publiée
par quelqu'un de la cnam en 2019
il était distribué 36 millions de
comprimés sans ordonnance et d'un coup
on décide qu'on n'a plus le droit du
tout d'utiliser ça donc il ya quelque
chose dont celui qui a aidé à décider de
ça moi je vous assure que lui l'a fait
de faute et après on demand même
l'azithromycine on peut plus donner 5
noeuds au pâtis suspecte qu il attendait
c'est le médicament le plus utilisé au
pâtis aux états unis on ne mangeait pas
ces données en france mais aux états
unis
tous les ans il ya une personne sur huit
qui prendre l'azithromycine donc pour
transformer ces trucs en prison violence
voulait il faut avoir quand même
alors bien sûr si vous utilisez des
doses déraisonnable mais c'est comme le
doliprane sait si vous doublez la dose
maximale ne donnait pas donc c'est les
médicaments dangereux si on les utilise
pas à des posologies à des à des doses
qui sont normales moi j'utilise ça
depuis 25 ans le placali pour les
maladies dont je suis spécialisé à 600
mg par jour et on leur donne pendant
deux ans donc on fait des dosages tous
les mois c'est mais des choses qu'on
maîtrise donc si vous voulez d'un coup
vous nous dites que c'est pour ça que
quand le papier du lendemain est sorti
lundi à 10 % de morts vous imaginez bien
que je crois qu'il ya 10 % de morts
puisque nous on en était déjà 3000
personnes contre été avec ça et j'avais
moins avant sa tt 3000 personnes avec ça
donc c'était pas possible
600 morts qu'ils soient passées
inaperçues j'ai pas vu mon chez moi il
ya deux morts parmi les gens qui sont
passés derrière lui en est mort 36 ans
tous les chez 3m entre c'est pas des
données de big data c'est des vrais
données de docteur m'a regardé on a
ressorti le dossier on a fait des
autopsies verbale c'est de comprendre de
quoi il était mort d'ailleurs 30 % qui
était membre surinfections bactériennes
donc encore une fois ça je crois qu'il y
avait il ya appris ce débat a pris un
tour qui est tout à fait fantastique
n'était pas raisonnable et il y avait un
véritable problème c'est que les malades
c'est au docteur de les soigner c'est
pas une dérive qui est que de maintenant
un mois j'étais en désaccord déjà là
pour dire c'était on aller vacciner les
gens restent à ces médecins généralistes
qui devait le faire on a on a mis des
années avant de
remonté sur la vaccination antigrippale
à cause de ça d'ailleurs on a dit au
médecin s'est plu à vous à faire ça vous
savez pas faire c'est nous qui allons
faire le maximum si on tirait pas donc
l'idée que l'état se saisisse de tâches
qui sont du soin usuelles si vous voulez
à la place des médecins et leur
interdisent de faire autre chose qui
sont banales je ne suis pas d'accord et
pour le dire d'ailleurs tout à fait
officiellement je suis surpris que
l'ordre des médecins et accepter une
chose pareille moi si j'avais été
président de l'ordre des médecins
ce qu'à dieu regarde j'aurais
démissionné immédiatement parce que
c'est la responsabilité des médecins de
faire pour le mieux dans leur dans
l'état de leurs connaissances et
d'ailleurs quand pour beaucoup si vous
me posez la question quand nous avons
décidé est basé sur nos résultats de
commencer à l'utiliser ce à chaque
médecin individuellement dans le soin
courant je m'étais assuré auprès du
directeur général de la santé qui a bien
compris les choses de même manière que
moi et bien sûr j'ai la trace de semaine
les médecins doivent faire pour le mieux
pour leurs malades en leur âme et
conscience compte tenu de notre état de
connaissances et de l'aider priver de ça
est quelque chose qui s'en je ne sais
même pas si c'est constitution d'alpage
je me pose la question c'est vous qui
savez moi j'ai des doutes sur le fait
même que ce soit constitutionnel